Barack Obama spent an outsized portion
of his presidency lecturing Americans
about illegal immigration unilaterally
suspended prosecutions of a wide swath
of illegal immigrants through his
executive amnesty meanwhile railing all
about the evils of the Republicans he
ripped Donald Trump's supposed
xenophobia over from strict anti-illegal
immigration proposals but Obama and
Democrats don't actually care about
illegal immigrants in fact they would
actually prefer that illegal immigrants
retain that status so they can be used
as a political sword against Republicans
the fact is on full display this morning
after a senior policy adviser to Obama
said Obama would not confer a blanket
pardon on illegal immigrants Cecilia
muñoz who's a domestic policy adviser
she said quote I know that people are
hoping for use of a pardon Authority as
a way to protect people it's ultimately
not for a couple of reasons one is the
general pardon Authority is generally
designed for criminal violations not
civil but it also doesn't confer legal
status only Congress can do that and so
ultimately it wouldn't protect a single
soul from deportation so it's not an
answer here for this population that by
the way was also true of Obama's
deferred action for childhood arrivals
and deferred action for parents of
Americans program its daca and DAPA they
didn't grant citizenship or prevent
future deportations they merely stopped
deportations here and now pardoning
illegal immigrants would remove the
legal pretext for deportation other
crimes such as fraud if you're using a
social security number that's false that
would still be prosecutable but it might
not be punishable with deportation in
fact Obama could pardon those crimes as
well removing all legal grounds for
prosecution
now this isn't making the case Obama
should pardon illegal immigrants of
course it would be the essence of
lawlessness a gross abuse of the
executive power but Obama hasn't
typically cared about any of that in the
past including on illegal immigration
and that's the point Obama doesn't want
to protect the illegal immigrants in any
real way without giving them full voting
rights he wants them to be stuck in
limbo so Democrats can claim they're
victimized by evil Republicans that's
why Democrats did not push comprehensive
immigration reform when they controlled
both houses of Congress from 2008 to
2010 stop with the routine in which
Democrats are deeply concerned about
illegal immigrants as anything but
political tools they simply aren't I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
tons to get to today here on the bench
Shapiro and we will get to it all we
have the mailbag coming up a little bit
later you have to subscribe subscribe to
daily wire comm become a part of the
mailbag but we have lots coming up in
the mailbag plus another epic things I
hate lots of things to hate lately which
is just makes me happy I know but first
we begin by saying hello to our
advertisers over at hint commies hint
water so if you think that water is kind
of boring because it kind of is if you
are constantly looking for something
that peps up the taste of water without
adding the calories hint is the best way
to go about doing that
we got bottles of hint water and they
are really fantastic it's it doesn't add
any calories that's all natural it's
organic and it has just a taste of
flavor and it's really great it's
watermelon peach mango grapefruit and
many more and it's in I'm telling you
like I drink it my wife drinks it my
children drink it and they love it it's
it's it's very difficult to go back to
regular water after you've had hints and
that's not because it's all written with
sugar or anything it isn't it's because
it's really good it's really refreshing
you can down a bottle of this stuff like
nothing and right now if you go to drink
hint calm slash Ben drink hint calm
slash Ben then you get their normal pack
which is 24 which is 24 bucks for only
$15 so you get it basically 1/3 off $24
to $15 you get pineapple watermelon
Crisp Apple and Blackberry my personal
favorite is I really like the blackberry
I think it's really good so hint water
is really good stuff you're gonna want
to check it out and it is beware it is
addictive I mean once you once you start
drinking it it's it's difficult to stop
drinking hint water excellent stuff
alrighty so we begin today with a
continuation of a theme a little bit
from yesterday and that of course is
this the situation with with carriers so
one of the things that I've been
preaching I'm going to continue to
preach here is that we need to call out
Trump when he's wrong and we need to
compliment him when he's right I know
the my good friend Andrew Clavin doesn't
feel the same way I know Clavin I had
this conversation off air just before
the program I was talking about this
carrier deal which I'll explain in just
a minute and why I think it's a problem
and he was saying yeah but overall Trump
is doing a good job I said I may very
well agree that overall Trump is doing a
pretty good job but that doesn't require
to ignore when he does things that are
bad see that argument the Trump overall
is good
that's an election argument that's an
argument that he's gonna be better than
Hillary for example but Hillary's no
longer in the picture now your
obligation as a citizen is to make sure
the President does as many things as you
can get him to do that you want him to
do right your obligation is to hold him
accountable and he does things that are
wrong as my obligation as a citizen -
it's not my obligation to sort of sign
off and just say oh well now he's been
elected he's popular that means that he
can do whatever he wants and so long as
he gives me more good than bad I'm just
gonna shut up and sit here that's not my
job it's actually a non sequitur okay if
you have a friend and your friend
embezzles from you and your wife comes
to you and she says you know your friend
just embezzled so yeah but overall he's
a good friend that's a non-sequitur that
doesn't deal with the main issue which
is that he just embezzled from you you
might want to address the embezzlement
if you don't want future embezzlement I
would prefer to stop Donald Trump from
ruining his presidency with bad policy
than I would to just compliment him when
he thinks that he does things that are
bad I think the carrier deal is bad and
let me explain why I think the carrier
deal is bad so the best way for me to
explain why I think the carrier deal is
bad is number one let me explain to you
hey let me say it state the problem the
problem is not just that the carrier
deal is bad for people who missed it
carrier is an air conditioning and
heating manufacturer located in Indiana
they were gonna shift a thousand jobs to
Mexico and another not and they say
they're not going to basically because
the state of Indiana offered them some
tax incentives and also because Donald
from threaten them that's basically what
it comes down to according to the New
York Times or others from Politico Jean
moots a former Indiana lieutenant
governor who sits on an agency board in
Indiana he told POLITICO carrier turned
down a previous offer from that board
before the election that offered all
these tax incentives for carrier to stay
in Indiana he said he thinks the choice
is driven by concerns from carriers
parent company United Technologies that
it could lose a portion of its roughly
6.7 billion dollars in federal contracts
so in other words what happened here is
that it cost carrier something like 65
million dollars to keep these jobs in
Indiana and so the question was why
would four or five million dollars of
tax incentives from Indiana keep those
jobs there and the answer is they
wouldn't right Pence offered this to
carrier before
that's crony capitalism in and of itself
but he offered it to them before carrier
turned it down now Trump selected and
suddenly there
vers themselves they didn't reverse
themselves because of Trump's regulatory
and tax policy that be a good thing
right that would be great if carrier
said listen now the business climate is
awesome we're staying right here that
would be great that would be good Trump
but it's bad Trump if from goes to them
and says I'm threatening you if you
leave then I am going to take all of
this taxpayer money I'm not gonna spend
it with you I wouldn't spend even more
taxpayer money with your competitor
because here's the thing right these
every Defense Department technology
contract every Defense Department
contract by law has to go through a
bidding process and that bidding process
requires you to show that you can
provide the best product for the
cheapest so that means that presumably
as the if a wall is obeyed then the
Defense Department contracts with United
Technologies were the best contracts
that were available that's the whole
goal of having a bidding process now
Trump is saying I know that was the best
deal available and it's still the best
deal available but screw that I'm gonna
spend twice as much money on some other
company just to punish United
Technologies because I want my headline
from them and I want my headline right
now I want the headline that says that I
saved a thousand jobs so I can go around
the country bragging about how I saved a
thousand jobs this is called economic
fascism it is and that's not that's not
linked in any way to to fascism with
regard to race or fascism with regard to
religion economic fascism is an actual
economic philosophy it's called
corporatism that believes that the
federal government should pick winners
and losers and it originated in in Italy
with with Mussolini this notion that the
government should should pick winners
and losers that basically corporate a
corporation and corporatism they all
they share the same root and that root
is Corp right Corbett's corpse right
wait they're talking about body right
the idea is that the entire economy is
like a body and the federal government
any government should decide which parts
of the economy should be which parts of
the body so you don't want you don't
want three hands you want two hands and
that means that the government is going
to decide which two companies should be
those two hands this is very dangerous
stuff it's top-down government-run
economics and that always results in
less useful economic development it
results in worse business deals it
results in spending more taxpayer money
and results in more regulation none of
this is good stuff and just because
Donald Trump got a good headline out of
it doesn't make it a good thing and just
because you think that he got a good
headline out of it because we want to
keep jobs in America and so he was doing
the right thing to keep jobs in America
now we're gonna flashback
now we're gonna flashback okay here's
the flashback the flashback is to 2009
here's Barack Obama in 2009 is February
2009 right after he's elected and you're
gonna see Barack Obama do the exact same
routine at caterpillar this is in Peoria
Illinois looks a lot younger obviously
this is in 2009 February 2009 and
conservatives ripped him a new one over
this as well they should have yesterday
Jim the head of Caterpillar said that if
Congress passes our plan this company
will be able to rehire some of the folks
who were just laid off and that's a
story I'm confident will be repeated at
companies across the country companies
that are currently struggling to borrow
money selling their products struggling
to make payroll but could find
themselves in a different position when
we started implementing the plan rather
than downsizing they may be able to
start growing again rather than cutting
jobs they may be able to create them
again that's the goal at the heart of
this plan to create jobs and not just
any jobs not just make work jobs but
putting people to work doing the work
that America needs done
repairing our infrastructure modernizing
our schools and our hospitals promoting
so that's Barack Obama circa February
2009 talking about how caterpillar had
pledged the daring keep the jobs there
now the CEO of Caterpillar came out very
shortly after he said well no we never
promised that we were gonna do anything
like that but the headline was already
out Obama had already claimed the
caterpillar was going to save all these
jobs because of his stimulus package
right and conservatives rightly went
nuts in 2013 and Obama's State of the
Union address he named checked calor at
caterpillar
they said look at all the jobs that I
personally have saved by using the
federal government as this cramdown
mechanism by threatening people and
cajoling people and giving them special
stimulus packages look at all the jobs
that I've saved including in places like
caterpillar our first priority is making
America a magnet for new jobs in
manufacturing after shedding jobs for
more than 10 years our manufacturers
have added about 500,000 jobs over the
past three caterpillar there's bringing
jobs back from Japan
Ford is bringing jobs back from Mexico
and this year
we'll start making Macs in America again
birthdays we can burman then he would go
on to suggest that we use the Department
of Defense
you may notice similarity use the
Department of Defense to create programs
to fund all of these places to continue
to keep jobs in America right it was bad
when this happened because number one he
wasn't telling the truth you don't
create jobs in America by redistributing
income from taxpayers to companies you
don't create jobs in America by giving
special tax incentives to companies that
would be more productive elsewhere
that's not how you create jobs the way
that you create jobs in America is by
removing taxes and removing regulations
and not removing taxes for one company
removing taxes for all companies
otherwise you are just granting special
favors to one company at the expense of
a competitor carrier is not the only air
conditioner and heating manufacturer in
the United States and when you grant
them a special tax incentives sure you
might save the thousand jobs there but
how about all the people who have to pay
the extra money for the stimulus how
about all the people who are competing
with carrier who are gaining jobs
because they're doing a better job than
carrier and building up their own jobs
base and now they're screwed because
they have to cut workers because they
can't compete with carrier which is
getting a thumb on the scale from the
federal government and nobody wants to
look at the the unintended consequences
of government intervention ISM because
it's too easy to see that specific
headline carrier saves thousand jobs in
Indiana but how is the question not what
happened how did it happen
the essence of fascism lies in somebody
saying I did it it happened it's
happened the fight against fascism
relies on you saying ok I need to know
how and whether that was good
fascism relies on people saying the
sausage has been created here is the
sausage the essence of republicanism SMO
our republicanism the essence of
democracy is you saying how did the
sausage get made and was that legitimate
right that is you being a good citizen
and so it's not being a bad citizen to
ask how this happened and whether it's a
good thing it's not being anti-american
to make sure that the methods that were
used to do this we're good and not bad
and by the way you have to extend the
logic out Paul Krugman who is an idiot
on economics except for some trade
theory
Paul Krugman when he when he looked at
this this morning he says well Barack
Obama created you know more jobs than
this you'd have to do what what Trump
did you'd have to do that every day for
every week for the next 30 years in
order to save the number of jobs that
Obama save
in the auto bailout and to a certain
extent he's right if you believe that
stimulus if you believe that special
incentives if you believe special
giveaways save jobs then why not just
blow it up and that's actually Trump's
plan you talked about one trillion
dollar infrastructure plan which is just
another boondoggle these infrastructure
plans are boondoggles
this is populism it's not conservatism
it's not conservatism it has nothing to
do with conservatism and in a little
while I want to talk about a Steven
Moore piece that is really egregious
here but I just want to show you how far
we've come
here's Sean Hannity and Ann Coulter
circa 2009 ripping on president obama
saying he's going to keep American jobs
in America by granting stimulus
discovered what was actually in this
bill yep they were rejecting it in
droves yeah so what I don't understand
with all the bad nominees and the tax
cheats and closing down Gitmo and
weakening our defenses Barack Obama and
a little over two weeks was as Victor
Davis Hanson said on the verge of an
implosion why would the rock that help
him bail him out here and that's why he
went on TV and started claiming we were
going to go in the Great Depression if
we didn't pass this massive socialist
bill I I am as once again awed by the
wisdom of the American people and a week
ago this bill had like 80 percent
support as of today it's 37 percent
support and I don't think anybody's read
the whole bill it's twice the size of
war and peace but people just find out
more and more what is in this bill and
support for it is collapsing so Obama
got there so you got in saying rightly
about the stimulus bill the more we find
out about it the more we don't like it
and now today we have people saying we
don't need to know what Trump did what
does it matter what was in this deal why
does it matter does it really matter at
all there's it and that's that sort of
what stephen moore says today stephen
moore has this amazing piece a national
review stephen moore is an economist for
the wall street journal very free market
guy supposedly and and he had peace
today at national review in which he
said that the era of reagan is over and
it's worth going through here a little
bit but in order for you to see me go
through it and i think it's important
you need to go to daily wire calm and
subscribe you need to go there and
subscribe it right now over at daily
wire.com $8 a month will get you access
to daily wire
com+ if you get an annual subscription
then you get a free cup free signed copy
of my book you get access to the mailbag
we're doing the mailbag today which is
awesome we're adding a we're adding I'll
tell you off the record but it's on the
record but is it I'll tell you that
we're gonna be adding a store to the to
the site in the next couple of months
and you get massive discounts from that
if you're a subscriber daily wire.com is
the place to go for all of this to join
us at the largest conservative podcast
in America
[Music]
you